Ellen you are a corporate lawyer you
focus on foreign and domestic banks and
yet given your busy life with your
family you're a mother of two children
you find the time to give so much to
Yale you were the chair of the board of
governors and now you serve as chairman
emeritus and you also chair yell women
how do you do it and why do you do that
I can't answer how I do it it's a deep
dark secret I can talk a little bit
about that I I am compelled to do it
when people ask me why I volunteer for
Yale my historic answer is that somebody
asked me somebody asked me a long time
ago to participate in one yell activity
and that led me to participate in yet
another and another and I found that as
I went through it the more I engaged
with other yelled volunteers the more I
wanted to do it it's it's hard to
explain actually you know I asked Julian
Bond a similar question how did he
become involved in activism and he said
because someone asked me yeah it's so
important to ask